autour du château de vincennes
aujourd'hui le spectacle de dimanche
matin ne fait pas relâche les arbres
déracinés ou pliées par le vent font
concurrence aux carcasses de voitures
prisonnière des colosses de bois paris a
perdu près d'un tiers de ces arbres
environ 140 milles sur les 485 milles
que comptait la capitale avant le coup
de tabac de ce week-end et sur le fond
des lendemains de tempête
françoise de panafieu à ce matin occuper
seul le terrain sinistré en tant
qu'adjointe au maire de paris en charge
des parcs et jardins elle s'est déplacée
pour faire passer un message de prudence
il faut que la population sache que dans
les trois semaines qui viennent ces
boissons dangereux parce que des arbres
sont menaçants même s'ils n'ont pas
l'air ils ont pu être ébranlée par le
vent et nous demandons à la population
de bien vouloir se tenir aux abords des
bois ne pas trop pire entrée de telle
sorte qu'elles puissent nous laisser
faire notre travail d'estimations et
dans trois semaines c'est bois lui
seront rendus d'une manière parfaitement
sur trois semaines pour les bois pas de
délai fixé en revanche pour les
cimetières parisiens particulièrement
touchés celui du père lachaise les
marronniers n'ont pas tenu le souffle et
plus de 200 sépultures ont été brisés
par la chute des arbres tous les
cimetières sont fermées aux promeneurs
jusqu'à nouvel ordre certainement
plusieurs semaines pour sécuriser les
visites les dégâts subis par le
patrimoine vert ne sont pas encore
chiffrés par la mairie ils sont estimés
à plusieurs dizaines de millions de
francs